all right i got some good news i have
three quick headlines stuff you need to
know
parlor just dealt a major blow in an
effort to get back online a judge ruling
that amazon
does not have to temporarily restore web
services for the social media platforms
while the companies continue to battle
out in court amazon d platform parlor
after the january 6 riot at the capitol
they blamed them washington d.c mayor
muriel bowser lifting the ban on indoor
dining
in our nation's capital starting at 5
a.m tomorrow restaurants will now be
allowed to operate at 25 percent
capacity to close
out inauguration week i think that's
great but the mayor did not offer any
science to support this decision in case
you were wondering
there were almost twice as many new
coveted 19 cases in dc yesterday
as there were on election day november
third
and finally white house press secretary
jen saki is now defending president joe
biden's decision to take off his mass
last night
just hours after signing executive order
that would stop him from taking his mask
off last night watch
joe biden often talks about uh it is not
just important the
example of power but the power of our
example was that a good example for
people who are watching i think we have
big
bigger issues to to worry about at this
moment in time exactly he also went on
she wanted
to say he's celebrating that's right we
can take our mask off before celebrating
and only joe biden can celebrate
meanwhile
president joe biden's latest round of
executive orders you saw that yesterday
as he as he muddled through and kind of
mumbled through his mask
cracking down especially hard on the oil
and gas industry
they say it must be done to slow the
progress of climate change but
if you're one of the thousands of people
who lose your job because of that don't
panic
pete buddha judge has your back he says
you can find a new one job that is so
for those workers the answer is somebody
else will get a job the answer is that
we are very eager to see those workers
continue to be employed in
good paying union jobs even if they
might be different ones
nice uh here to react now somebody who
has a job thankfully with the new york
post miranda devine
miranda sound a little callous if you
lose your job go get another
they never thought of that when you lose
a job to go find another
it's just so typical of the left and the
democrats
people like pete buddha judge who live
in an ivory tower
and have never done a an honest days of
you know laboring work at ever in their
life and they have no respect for it
and uh it's very easy for them to tell
people to go and get a job
go and learn to code i remember joe
biden saying that to
coal miners it just shows exactly no
understanding in manufacturing jobs and
also what happens
if you learn to code is coding jobs are
the first ones that get outsourced
to india so you you're out of a job
anyway
yeah it's like if you get cut from a
football team why don't you try baseball
uh not bad maybe you don't want to so
here's what i'm talking about in terms
of jobs these aren't estimates these are
facts
so he says i'm not going to pay for the
wall anymore we're going to stop it
the problem is you already paid for the
wall and the problem is they already
made the steal
so now you're going to pay a fine it
doesn't matter we can just add to the
deficit
to get rid of 270 000 tons of steel
ballads
they'll now travel they'll either
destroy them or store them that's going
to cost additional money
it's going to cost between 5 and 10 000
jobs because they're going to be working
it's paid for
for the next two years putting up the
additional wall and this is a guy
senator joe biden who paid in 2006
to secure to uh signed on to the secure
fence act
to build 650 miles of wall so the effort
is not even sincere you can't even say
he wants to stop it
no this is uh someone as we know who has
very flexible morality
and uh pre doesn't practice what he
preaches and
there's another few thousand jobs gone
another few thousand in the pipeline
you know we're in the middle of a
pandemic we have uh
joblessness has just skyrocketed and
he's reducing border protection at a
time when
uh we've got a pandemic and there's
coronavirus rampant among people
south of the border who are on their way
here and
you know that is what you call a super
spreader event that joe biden claims
that he's so paranoid
about so the xl pipeline was
commissioned in 2015 and they said well
it's going to be environmentally
damaging so five times
barack obama's administration checked it
out it has zero effect
on the environment in fact if you use
rail or cars it has a 28
to 42 percent higher emissions rate on
the environment
but he said no we're not going to build
it anyway so trump puts it into action
they start building it
and the first thing that president biden
does yesterday is stop it
which means at least 10 000 union jobs
are stopped
and american steel is not used please
tell us what his rationale is
he's just cow towing to these far left
environmental groups
who they want us to stop using fossil
fuels at all
they have no respect for the fact that
america became
energy independent in 2019 and
that that means that we don't have any
reliance on
overseas oil which is a good thing it
means that we're
not prone to get into overseas wars it
means that we have
cheap abundant energy which we do in
this country this country is blessed
but we are supposed to leave it locked
in the ground and
uh you know somehow what go back to
living in caves
what i think was most frustrating is i
wanted to believe
america united i think he absolutely is
right that's the theme little things
like this saying you know i was going to
get rid of the xl pipeline but it's
going to cost so many jobs i'm going to
meet with mitch mcconnell in two weeks
about this you know the wall is already
paid for along with the technology it
could be effective i understand it's
politically a third rail
we're going to examine this a little
while longer instead
it's uh if you're if you're a refugee
you get to stay
and if you're uh building the wall you
get to stop miranda devine we're going
to read you tomorrow in the new york
post thanks so much
thanks so much brian all right